si madame la parole est à monsieur jean
pierre barbier monsieur le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre j'y associe
mon collègue jean pierre door alléluia
marisol touraine a sauvé la vieille dame
qu'elle disait moribonde la sécurité
sociale une nouvelle affirmation
péremptoire et sans fondement selon une
méthode éprouvée éprouvante que nous
avons subi tout au cours de ce
quinquennat
cette nouvelle annonce est contestée par
la cour des comptes et par les chiffres
le déficit cumulé et cette année
équivalent à celui de 2012 est
malheureusement toujours aussi abyssal
près de 153 milliards
vous avez réussi améliorer faiblement un
résultat annuel
mais à quel prix et pour combien de
temps faut-il vous rappeler que pour la
branche vieillesse c'est la réforme de
2010 celle d'eric woerth qui porte ses
fruits aujourd'hui que vous n'avez pas
voté faut-il vous rappeler votre hold up
sur les allocations familiales
faut-il vous rappeler que vous avez
mises à terre l'industrie pharmaceutique
ce qui induit des milliers de
licenciements et la perte de notre
leadership
faut-il vous rappeler que vous n'avez
conduit aucune forme structurel de
l'hôpital faut-il vous rappeler que vous
n'avez pas anticipé le financement de
produits innovants prenant ainsi le
risque que nos malades ne puissent pas
bénéficier de ces progrès thérapeutique
faut-il vous rappeler vos artifice
comptable est votre politique
d'augmentation des recettes par les
taxes et cotisations diverses
non les français s'en souviennent et ça
et s'en souviendront et comme eux comme
la cour des comptes
nous ne sommes pas convaincus par cette
dernière supercherie alors monsieur le
premier ministre
espérez vous cachez ce bilan calamiteux
par une dernière promesse électorale en
augmentant le prix de la consultation
médicale pas de 2 euros une augmentation
mérité mais tardive et incertaine car là
encore les mutuelles ne vous suivent
plus
merci
la parole est à madame ségolène neuville
secrétaire d'état chargé des personnes
handicapées de la lutte contre
l'exclusion
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
je veux d'abord excusé la ministre de la
santé et des affaires sociales mme
marisol touraine lots plaît s'il vous
plaît allez a dû partir à une réunion
des directeurs hospitalier alors
monsieur le député je peux vous répondre
tout à fait sincèrement et honnêtement
c'est vrai fléau sur jacob
il y avait bien un génie ce que répond
qui dès lors qu'il ya une bonne nouvelle
refuse de reconnaître ces bonnes
nouvelles
moi j'appelle ça des oiseaux de mauvaise
augure oui il y à des hommes et des
femmes politiques qui de façon mais
continu continu de d'apporter des
mensonges en réalité à la france et aux
français parce que ne vous en déplaise
les comptes de la sécurité sociale vont
bien ne vous en déplaise
quand c'était vous qui étiez au pouvoir
oui il y avait plus de 17 milliards de
vous êtes de déficit et ne vous en
déplaise
la gauche est meilleur en gestion que la
droite et c'est ça la réalité
d'aujourd'hui parce que la réalité
d'aujourd'hui c'est que le déficit
aujourd'hui il est de 3,4 milliards
d'euros et que l'année prochaine en 2017
il sera de 400 millions d'euros et oui
c'est une bonne nouvelle
ne vous en déplaise ne vous en déplaise
vous étiez au pouvoir
vous n'avez fait que des
déremboursements vous avez fait des
franchises et les déremboursements
nous nous avons créé de nouveaux droits
oui nous avons remboursé les vga 100%
oui nous avons remboursé la
contraception pour les mineures oui nous
avons pris en charge les malades de
l'hépatite c est justement nous avons
négociées avec l'industrie sur le
montant des médicaments de l'hépatite c
ce que vous n'avez jamais su faire avec
les médicaments innovants oui nous avons
mis en oeuvre les génériques
nous avons fait en sorte que les
génériques soit plus prescrit et cela a
permis de diminuer le déficit
nous avons fait la prime d'activité nous
avons créé le comte pénibilité tout ça
ce sont de nouveaux droits
et oui ça vous ferait
de le reconnaître mais